Uh, Al Abbasi, how you doing?
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So, we just want to talk about the
Islamic dilemma.
>> I'm sorry.
>> The Islamic dilemma. Let's talk about
it.
>> You want to talk about the Islamic
dilemma? Sounds good.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. What do you want to talk about it?
>> I say it's it's facious especially
coming from you guys because you have
Matthew 23 where Jesus generally
confirms the Jewish law while
consciously.
>> Yeah.
>> So, you're talking about Matthew 23?
>> Yes.
>> All right. So, do you want to pull that
up so we can read it? I'm happy to read
it because the argument I'm guessing
you're making, and you can correct me if
I'm wrong, is you're going to say that
Jesus confirms the Jewish law in the way
that the Quran confirms the prior
scriptures. Is that what you're going to
say?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, uh do you know what it
actually says, though?
>> Yeah, you can pull it up and read it.
>> Yeah. So, Matthew 23, then Jesus said to
the crowds and his disciples, the
scribes, and the Pharisees, sit in
Moses's seat. So do and observe whatever
they tell you but not the works they do
for they preach but do not practice. Now
I have a question for you. What is the
Greek word for so in verse three?
>> I don't know. You can educate me on
that.
>> So so it' be like uh maybe I'm
butchering the pron pronunciation. It's
like un and it means basically either so
or therefore.
It's a clause or it's a word that would
use to basically say because this
therefore that. So because the scribes
sit in the Pharisees seat or the
Pharisees sit in Moses seat therefore or
so do and observe whatever they tell
you. So it's qualified. Verse three is
qualified by verse two. Do you know do
you know why that's important?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So I'll just explain it. uh when
the scholars like Craig Kenir will note
that sitting in Moses's seat was a job
that basically meant they recite the
Torah and also if you notice the word uh
for tell it doesn't mean teach it mean
literally means to say or recite. So
when the scribes and the Pharisees sit
in Moses's seat aka read from the Torah
do what they recite or do what they say.
So yeah, and we completely agree when
they are telling us when they are
reading from the law, the Torah, we are
supposed to to do what they say because
we believe everything in the Torah
points to Jesus and the new covenant
ultimately. So how is that confirming
all of the teachings of the Pharisees?
>> No, it it confirms the Jewish law. Do
you agree there?
>> Of course, we think that the Torah is
confirmed by Jesus. I mean, John, it's
in John 5:39. You you search the
scriptures thinking it'll give you
eternal life, but you have failed to see
it points to me. So yeah, he confirms
the scriptures and he gives them the
proper interpretation of it.
>> Does he contradict it consciously?
>> No. No.
>> Really?
>> So, so the not notice the difference
between us and you is that
>> we're not saying that the Old Testament
is corrupted and that whatever aligns
with the New Testament is good and
whatever doesn't is corrupted. No, we're
the whole Old Testament and the New
Testament go together perfectly
handinand one dispensation to another.
while you're saying that while the Quran
confirms the Old and New Testament,
they're also they're also corrupted. And
so that's your dilemma. We don't we
don't have that dilemma.
>> The Quran generally confirms it while
consciously editing it.
>> When you say generally, that means
you're referring to the whole not.
>> Yeah, that's what it when you say in
general, like if I were to say um
Muslims are good people, did I just
generalize the Muslim community?
>> Yeah.
>> So you see how I'm referring to the
Muslim community as a whole? It's good
now. But that doesn't mean that there
ain't any exceptions.
>> It's I'm I'm disregarding the
exceptions. I'm appealing to the whole.
>> So when you're whenever you say that the
Quran is confirming the scriptures
generally, you're appealing to the
scriptures as a whole. You're
disregarding any exceptions.
>> Yes.
>> I got I got a question for you. That's
okay. Can I ask you a question?
>> Sure.
>> All right. Let's just say my name is
Joseph Smith.
>> Okay. I've got my book. It's called the
Book of Mormon. I believe this came from
God. But let's say also in this parallel
universe, I go go to the Middle East and
I say to Muslims, "Oh Muslims, you have
nothing to stand on unless you observe
the Quran, the Hadith, and what has been
revealed to you from your Lord. Would
you believe in the Book of Mormon?"
>> No.
>> Exactly. But what do we find in Surah
568? Allah speaks through Muhammad and
says, "Oh people of the book, you have
nothing to stand on unless you observe
the Torah, the Gospel, and what has been
revealed to you from your Lord."
Therefore, Allah is telling us
Christians to adhere to the Old and New
Testament because that's what's been
revealed to us from our Lord. Likewise,
if a so-called prophet came to you as a
Muslim, you would go to the Quran and
the Hadith, not some other scriptures.
Right.
>> Sure.
>> That's the that's the problem that
that's the Islamic dilemma. In Surah
568, Allah is speaking to us Christians
through Muhammad. And he says, "Stand on
your scriptures. That's where you need
to go to." Okay? Okay. So, we go to our
scriptures and we go, hey, this teaches
something completely contradictory to
the Quran. Therefore, we can judge this
is cannot be from God. But if we're
going to corrupt scriptures, then we
need to ask, why is Allah telling us to
go to corrupt scriptures? So, either
way, Islam is false.
>> Yeah. Firstly, yeah, the Quran confirms
the previous scriptures in a general
sense which were in 7th century Arabia
and it consciously edits it. For
example, okay, I have a question for
you. Where do you think Muhammad is
getting the stories from?
>> Getting what?
Where where do you think Muhammad is
getting these stories from?
>> From he's hearing random stories from
the various Jews, Christians, and pagans
around him. And he's that's why they
call him the ear. It's mentioned in
sewer nine. They tell him a bunch of
stories and he believes whatever he
hears.
>> Sure. No. Uh does he consciously
contradict those stories?
>> Does he consciously contradict like the
what we find in the New Testament and
Old Testament?
>> Yeah.
>> Is that what you're asking? Uh
>> yes. He consciously contradicts them in
multiple places. Yeah. No.
>> What what he's asking is does Muhammad
know because he's kind of switching it.
Does Muhammad know what the New
Testament and Old Testament say and is
consciously aware of what they say and
purposely contradicting them? That's
what he's asking.
>> I see. I misunderstood.
>> And so the answer to that is no. He
doesn't know the scriptures. However,
hearing these stories, he hears these
stories and he puts his own little twist
on them. So yeah, you can say that he
consciously twists the stories he hears.
>> Yeah. Then why does he say in that uh
Allah made heavens and the earth in six
days and he did not get any fatigue. So
he's responding to the story in Exodus
where God slept on the seventh day.
>> I'm sorry. Where where does it say that?
Where does it say that he's responding
to the story in Exodus about God
sleeping?
>> No, the tone is of responding tone.
>> Where do you get that from?
>> Oh, he says and he did not sleep. So why
would you even just say that he did not
sleep?
>> The Bible doesn't The Bible doesn't say
that God slept. So
>> it doesn't.
>> No.
>> Exodus.
>> Exodus doesn't say God slept.
>> I'll get
>> Do you mean rested?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So where does the Quran say that
in the Torah it says that God rested?
>> No, it doesn't say that. It says that
God did not rest. So it's in the tone of
responding.
>> So it's just it's just contradicting
what the Torah says.
>> Yes. And
>> that's Islamic dilemma.
>> Yeah. But this contradiction is a
conscious contradiction. So obviously
>> whether you want to say whether you want
to say that he does it on purpose that
he knows about it and he's contradicting
it or he does it accidentally it doesn't
change the issue. All you're saying now
is that Muhammad purposely creates the
Islamic dilemma.
>> No it changes because now the
confirmation would be a general
confirmation.
>> No where do you get that from? And again
general is is referring to the whole of
a thing. So stop using general
confirmation because you're saying what
we're saying. Prophetam generally
confirms the scriptures
>> while consciously editing.
>> Do you agree with Okay, I got a
question. Where when Allah tells us he's
confirming our scriptures in surah 24147
when he tells us to judge by the gospel
in surah 547 where does he also add
parts of it have been corrupted?
>> Yeah, let's go to the one where he says
to judge by it. Uh are you aware of the
context behind it? Are you going to go
to surah 548 with Muaymon?
>> Yeah.
>> No, I'm asking the context behind the
one which it says that judge by the
scripture
>> judged by the gospel. That'd be surah
547.
>> Yeah. What's the context behind it?
>> The context was is that the Jews had
come to him. If you read the full surah
because it starts in the section I'm
referring to starts in surah 543. The
Jews come to him ask him to judge
between a dispute between them and Allah
says why are they coming to you when
they have the Torah? And then Muhammad
adds oh also the uh Christians are to
judge by the gospel.
>> So the the whole the whole night to
judge with are judged with the
scriptures is particularly about the
ruling not particular ruling which is
found in the Quran and also in the Torah
and in not holistic.
>> So then where does Allah say in that
section only judge by like the legal
requirements? Why does he just say
generally as you started this you said
generally just you know generally judged
by the gospel generally judged by the
Torah. Where does he say no no I only
meant the legal aspects. Where does he
say that?
>> The context. The context clarify
something.
>> Well let's just read it then. I'll just
pull it up. Avery had to step out. He
got a phone call. But let me just pull
up sewer 5 because I'm I'm be very
curious to see where it says that in the
context here. Uh because if he unlike
with Matthew 23 we pointed out earlier
where there is that. So or there forward
in the middle. Okay, we don't see that
here. We see instead Muhammad saying
blanketly, this is how you judge. So I'm
going to go I'm going to start in verse
43 and I'll read from there. So but why
do they come to you for judgment when
they already have the Torah containing
Allah's judgments? Now I'm going to stop
pause right there because it says
already containing Allah's judgments.
Not
>> certain judgments on this matter, not
just a couple important judgments. It
just it contains Allah's judgment. So it
doesn't actually give us any criteria
right there to start on where to
>> distinct. But actually we think that the
life as a Jew
>> we're going we're going to the taps now.
We we're trying to go what the Quran
says. So let's just finish reading this.
So
>> then they turn then they turn away.
After all they are not believers.
Indeed, we revealed the Torah containing
guidance and light by which the prophets
who submitted themselves to Allah made
judgments for Jews. So too did the
rabbis and scholars judge according to
Allah's book with which they were
entrusted. In all of which they were
made keepers. So do not fear the people
fear me, nor trade my revelations for a
fleeting gain. And those who do not
judge by what Allah has revealed are the
disbelievers. We ordained for them in
the Torah a life for a life and an eye
for an eye, a nose for a nose, an ear
for an ear, and a tooth for tooth for a
tooth, and for wounds equal retaliation.
But whoever waves it charitably, it will
be atoned for them. And those who do not
judge by what Allah has revealed are the
wrongdoers. Then in the footsteps of the
prophets, we sent Jesus, son of Mary,
confirming the Torah revealed before
him. And we gave him the gospel
containing guidance and light and
confirming what was revealed in the
Torah, a guide and a lesson to the
God-fearing. So now we have the Torah
and the Gospel. And the gospel confirms
or the gospel confirms the Torah. Okay.
As a guide. Notice again, this is before
I even get to verse 47. It's confirming
it generally. That's what you said. It's
confirming it as a whole.
>> No, in this particular context, it's
confirming the ruling that is found in
the Torah.
>> Okay. Where in what I just read does it
say we're only confirming that ruling?
>> So we not cranest. We take the tough se
we take the we take the def clearly
indicate that it's confirming the
particular ruling.
>> Okay. So there are multiple tough sears
and we're getting different regarding
that. And again even with regard
regardless of the tough sears it said it
does not say the specific things you're
saying. It says it's confirming it
generally.
>> Yeah. I have no problem accepting that.
>> Say that again.
>> I have no problem accepting that it's
confirming generally too. There's
nothing wrong with it.
>> Okay.
>> But yeah, the verse 40 says, "Well,
Muham." So, what about that?
>> The Muhamm.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> What does Mahan mean?
>> Uh, it has multiple meanings in this
particular context. It means supreme
authority.
>> It means supreme authority. So let's go
to verse 48 because none of the early
tough seers that you were just
mentioning ever translate this supreme
authority. They translate as guardian,
trustworthy witness. Even modern
scholars like Shanthony say it means
like faithful servant. Uh if it would
mean something like supreme authority or
criterion, it would be using the word
the Arabic word fukan which is in sewer
253 when Allah says we gave to Moses and
Aaron the criterion. But I mean, even if
we were to translate it that way, it
doesn't make sense with the context. It
says, "We revealed to you a prophet, the
book with the truth, as a confirmation
of previous scriptures, and as a mumen
over them." Now, look, notice what it
says right after this. So, judge between
them by what Allah has revealed, and not
follow their desires over the truth that
has come to you to teach to each of you.
We have ordained a code of law and a way
of life. If Allah had willed, he would
have made you one community. But his
will is to test you uh with what he has
given each of you. So compete with each
with one another in doing good to allow
you will all return that he will inform
you of the truth regarding your
differences. So in the context it's not
saying the Quran is a criterion or a
supreme authority over the prayer
scriptures. It treats them as all
equals. Each community has their own
book that they're to judge by.
>> So that the the context doesn't support
your rendering of this. Neither do the
early tough sears.
>> Yeah. the each each community having
their own scriptures. It's talking about
the past and uh it the Quran clearly
says judge between both of them. So and
it
>> judge between what? Judge between what?
>> Scriptures. Scriptures.
>> It doesn't say that. It says judge
between them and do not follow their
vain desires. Do scriptures have vain
desires?
>> It's talking about the rabbis and
Pharisees. Don't judge just what Allah
has.
>> Exactly. So it's judge between these
rabbis, these people who have vain
desires. judge between them.
>> No.
>> Right.
>> No. No. That's my way.
>> Okay. Sorry. So, let's let's break this
down step by step. It says, "So, judge
between them by what Allah has revealed
to you and do not follow their vain
desires." So, the judge between them by
what Allah has revealed to you and do
not follow their them and the there is
the same thing. Them and the there is
the same thing. And do not follow their
vain desires. Whose desires?
>> It's talking about the rabbis and the
Pharisees.
>> Okay. So that means that they using the
Quran to judge between the rabbis and
the Pharisees, not the scriptures.
>> No, it says judge between them is
talking about the scriptures and their
desires is talking about
>> how how does how does that how does that
work in a sentence? In a in a sentence,
you're saying that so judge between them
by what the by by what Allah has
revealed to you and do not follow their
vain desires. The them and the there are
not the same subject.
>> No.
>> Where's the switch?
>> Okay. Start reading the verse from
starting and break it down piece by
piece.
>> What? Start reading the verse from the
beginning of it.
>> I I already did. I I just read this.
This is the part that's relevant. So
judge between them by what Allah has
revealed to you by what we revealed to
you and do not follow their vain
desires. The them and the there are the
same subject.
>> No, because you're you're ignoring the
the starting part of the verse
intentionally again.
>> All right, bro. I'mma um I'mma go ahead
and uh probably let somebody else up
because I can't I can't do this type of
dishonesty, man.
>> Yeah, it it there's no switch in
subject. You can't be saying there's a
magical switch or an imaginary switch
when there isn't there.
>> It says uh we have reviewed this book as
a supreme authority authority and judge
between them.
>> Doesn't say authority. He already just
broke that down to you
>> again. You brought up early tough
series. You wanted to know that. And the
moment I said, well, the tough seers
never actually define it as supreme
authority. Now you're like
and say it's an authority.
>> They say it's an authority.
>> Hold on. Who?
>> What was that?
>> I was just trying something.
>> Oh, okay. He's trying something. All
right. What What was going on?
>> Well, I'm I'm going to move on. Thanks,
uh, Alabasi, man. We We can't We can't
do this with If you're not going to be
honest with your own book, bro. But
thanks for coming.